hemos visto varios vídeos en el que se
explica que es el teorema de pitágoras y
su uso para conocer los lados de un
triángulo rectángulo e incluso para
conocer la distancia entre los puntos en
un plano cartesiano aquí vamos a
escribir teorema de pitágoras y
recordemos que éste dice que si yo tengo
un triángulo rectángulo triángulo
rectángulo aquí está mi ángulo recto y
si se es el lado que es opuesto a este
ángulo recto y es el lado más grande no
a este lado lo vamos a llamar hipotenusa
vamos a escribir toda la palabra aquí y
por hipotenusa la suma del cuadrado de
los otros dos lados va a ser igual al
cuadrado de ce a este lado lo vamos a
llevar a ya éste lo vamos a llamar b el
teorema de pitágoras nos dice que a
cuadrado más de cuadrada va a ser igual
a c cuadrada aquí escribimos se cuadrada
y ya en otros vídeos hemos usado esto
para resolver algunos problemas
ahora lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo
es desarrollar una prueba visual de este
teorema el teorema de pitágoras y para
comenzar a comprender esto permítanme
dibujar un diagrama y comenzamos este
diagrama dibujando un triángulo
rectángulo como este de acá
y este va a ser mi lado y este es mi
lado ven aquí tengo mi ángulo recto y
opuesto a este tengo mi lado ce y ahora
lo que voy a hacer es dibujar este mismo
triángulo pero rotando lo un poco ahora
van a ver a qué me refiero este es el
mismo triángulo que dibujé anteriormente
solo que lo he derrotado aquí está el
lado y aquí está el lado b y aquí está
el lado c ustedes pueden hacer esto
mismo con una hoja de papel y una regla
pueden dibujar este triángulo abc lo
pueden rotar o girar a la izquierda y
dibujarlo exactamente donde terminan su
triángulo anterior ahora lo voy a rotar
una vez más voy a dibujarlo de esta
manera rotado
aquí está el mismo triángulo lo
dibujamos así y nuevamente este es el
lado a el lado ve el lado ce y
recordemos que todos estos triángulos
son iguales es decir tienen las mismas
proporciones y ahora vamos a rotar una
vez más este mismo triángulo
vamos a dibujar este triángulo
exactamente aquí y una vez más este lado
de aquí es a este lado de acá es ve este
lado de aquí ese ahora sí vamos a ver
que tenemos aquí tenemos todos estos
ángulos rectos y tenemos un cuadrado
interno que se encuentra inscrito dentro
de estos ángulos rectos y si quieren
también les puedo demostrar que todos
estos de aquí son ángulos rectos todos
estos son ángulos rectos ustedes pueden
saber o no que la suma de todos los
ángulos dentro de un triángulo es igual
a 180 grados si llamamos a este ángulo x
y a este ángulo y sabemos que si sumamos
x más y más 90 grados tendremos 180 x
más y más 90 igual a 180 grados o
también podemos decir que si quitamos 90
a ambos lados de la ecuación
tendremos x
e igual a 90 lo único que hice aquí fue
quitar 90 en ambos lados de la ecuación
y estos ángulos xy ya los tenemos en
todos los demás triángulos pues todos
son el mismo triángulo aquí está este
ángulo aquí también lo mismo aplica para
el ángulo y aquí está este ángulo aquí
está el mismo ángulo y aquí también
ahora es posible que ustedes sepan o
quizás no que si tenemos tres ángulos
que forman una línea permítanme
dibujarlo si tenemos tres ángulos que
forman una línea el ángulo a el ángulo b
tops permítanme corregir esto el ángulo
b y el ángulo c
juntos forman pueden verlo como un
semicírculo entonces a mars ve más se va
a ser igual a 180 ha de ser igual a 180
los tres forman un arco de 180 grados
ahora si observamos esta sección de acá
esto que está formado por estos tres
ángulos x este ángulo recto de acá que
vamos a llamar y que no sé cómo llamar
que le vamos a poner ángulo z x más z
más ya va a ser igual a 180 grados lo
escribimos x más z aunque creo que
debería quedar x más jay-z igual a 180 y
ya sabemos que x massieu es igual a 90
90 maceta igual a 180 restamos 90 en
ambos lados de esta ecuación y quitamos
este 90 de acá 180 menos 90 y de este
lado también escribo en -90 iceta va a
ser igual a 90 grados aquí hemos
comprobado que todos estos ángulos
internos van a ser de 90 grados y los
lados tienen la misma longitud ce por lo
que tenemos un cuadrado
dentro de este diagrama ahora vamos a
tratar de calcular cuál
es el área de este cuadrado y hay dos
maneras de hacerlo vamos a analizarlas
la primera es una forma bastante
sencilla de encontrar el área si sabemos
que este lado vale c y este otro lado
vale c para encontrar el área
multiplicamos este lado por este otro
lado c por c si quiero conocer el área
de este cuadrado voy a tener que
cuadrada aquí escribimos área igual a se
cuadrada pero de qué otra manera podemos
calcular esta área bueno también podemos
decir que va a ser el área de este
cuadrado más grande de todo este
cuadrado de acá que estoy resaltando en
otro color menos el área de todos estos
triángulos estos triángulos que estoy
sombreando acá esta sería otra manera de
encontrar el área el área de este
cuadrado interno cuál es el área de este
cuadrado grande bueno cada lado mide a
más b
si queremos el área vamos a multiplicar
a b por a b o lo que es lo mismo a más b
al cuadrado y ésta va a ser el área del
cuadrado externo pero aún queremos saber
cuál es el área del cuadrado pequeño
vamos a escribir el área del cuadrado
pequeño entonces tenemos que quitar el
área de todos estos triángulos bueno el
área de cada uno tendremos que restar un
medio de el lado a por el lado b un
medio de borde
este es el área de uno de los triángulos
pero tenemos 1234 triángulos aquí así
que vamos a multiplicar esto por cuatro
y esta es otra forma un poquito más
laboriosa de encontrar el área de este
cuadrado interno y ahora vamos a hacer
un poco de álgebra vamos a simplificar
este lado derecho de esta ecuación
tenemos a más b por hamás b menos cuatro
por un medio de a por b todo esto nos
queda como a cuadrado
a más 2 x x b más b cuadrada y en esta
parte tenemos que tenemos pues tenemos
dos por a o por b ya que cuatro por un
medio es dos menos dos por a por b y
estas dos se cancelan lo que nos deja
con a cuadrada más b cuadrada finalmente
el área de este cuadrado interno que es
sé cuadrada es igual a cuadrada más b
cuadrada lo que nos demuestra que es el
teorema de pitágoras y así hemos
demostrado visualmente la validez del
teorema de pitágoras que se refiere a
triángulos rectángulos que tienen como
hipotenusa el lado c espero que les haya
gustado esta demostración